all right so for the past 15 years Duke
Nukem has existed in myth and legend
only like hobgoblins of the g-spot and
I'm about to get a look at it I can't
show you but I can't tell you what I see
so let's go baby all right so I just saw
four minute video for Duke Nukem Forever
and I plays the game for 15 minutes I
can tell you it's a lot of fun as a
first-person shooter it's really nothing
special but I mean Dukes new comes like
if doom and Leisure Suit Larry alike had
a kid it's raunchy its adult BAE it's a
lot of fun all the one-liners you
remember they're back all the weapons
you remember they're back a couple of
new ones if you like one-liners sarcasm
narcissism and first-person shooters
which is everyone's favorite melting pot
then you're probably going to want to
check it out but if you're a fan of
solid first-person shooters like I said
it's nothing special but it's good to
see the deuce back all right so for the
past 15 years Duke Nukem has existed and
myth and legend only like Hobgoblin to
the g-spot but we're gonna get